cette dame a décidé de quitter la
résidence les floralies
son fils est venu la chercher pour la
ramener chez lui
c'est en écoutant le reportage diffusé
sur nos ondes hier que plusieurs proches
de résidents ont été pris que 12
personnes sont mortes de la coved 19
entre ses murs je suis quand même en
outre est vraiment là et je les écris la
résidence
j'ai envoyé un courriel à la résidence
est pas normal ok les premiers a été
formé on aurait dû le savoir avant vous
sa mère de 81 18 ans marguerite demeure
au centre depuis le 11 mars
elle va bien mais la situation angoisse
la famille on est très inquiète parce
que on ne sait pas quelles sont les
mesures de sécurité et de prévention qui
sont appliqués à l'intérieur de
l'établissement en fait on sait même pas
s'ils y ont appliqué des mesures de
prévention les proches de plusieurs
résidents sont dans le noir
il déplore le manque de transparence et
de communication de l'établissement ou
ignorées jusqu'à 16 9 ma tante a été
infectée par la coved 19 raconte cette
dame mais c'est toute l'information que
nous avons reçue dans un message envoyé
aux proches des résidents la direction
du csld les floralies indique que le
ministère de la santé a effectué une
inspection ici pendant quatre heures
hier soir
elle dit que toutes les unités et
plusieurs résidants ont été visités mais
qu'aucun correctif majeure n'a été
exigée
le sinus de l'ouest de l'île envoyé un
médecin des infirmières en renfort pour
épauler l'établissement l'une d'entre
elles qui a voulu conserver l'anonymat
affirme que plusieurs résidants atteints
de problèmes cognitifs ne respectent pas
les consignes d'isolement et les classes
se promène partout dans chaque état
comme à l'entrée des ascenseurs du sont
là c'est qu'ils essayent les personnels
essaye de se protéger mais je vois une
lacune aussi sur les techniques de
prévention 10 seulement rien pour
rassurer les proches des résidents ici
olivier bachand radio canada montréal